[Music]
oh
[Applause]
welcome back to another edition of own
head of the week
welcome gabe
hey hey what's up oh well i'm just
excited excited for the winner here uh
although um we're kind of at the point
to where this winner has kind of lost uh
her trendiness because we've had other
boneheads step in here
yeah one of them being uh maybe a
dishonored mention from this week
yeah it's um
we can't keep up with this bonehead
thing we might have to do like bonehead
of the hour type thing right i know it's
i feel like it's not working yeah the
the
they they keep it's like they're they
they've got their bench of players and
they're just throwing subs in every
single day
right and then it's any given toes here
no really yeah i mean like within two
days or three days that person is like
not so much
in the news anymore and there's someone
else that was doing something
equally or just as dumb
right well you see our contestants there
you see our contestants there this week
they were marjorie taylor green uh louis
louie gohmert and then thomas massey
which no one really knew who the [ __ ]
thomas massey was yeah
yeah i think that was definitely working
toward his advantage of uh nobody knows
who i am and so nobody knows the shitty
thing i did or rather the dumb thing i
did maybe maybe that's why he did it was
to uh you know one up the other bone
heads i don't know
it's hard to tell what these with these
[ __ ] idiots but uh we do have it we
do have a clear winner of the week
um it was closed for a little bit it was
it was very close it wasn't like last
week last week lauren bobert like and it
was because of the jihad squad videos
that patriot takes was posting uh [ __ ]
out of the gate yeah right she got like
80 and [ __ ] stayed there right yeah
it was hard hard to recover no one else
could don't come back right so here's
here's the poll that you guys took this
week uh on at tony michael's pod
remember that is where you go to
uh cast your vote for bonehead of the
week so follow us over on twitter at
tonymichaelspot also follow at the
tonymichaels and at i am gabe sanchez go
follow us on there you'll find the poll
uh there at toni michael's pod on
twitter but it looks if you look here
louie gohmert it doesn't even look like
anyone knows who the [ __ ] he is at this
point right right i mean he's definitely
had his moments to shine before
but keep in mind this is like uh you
know he was
he was trending
uh and then you know by the
that was over the weekend last week you
know and then by the beginning of the
week boom he was um
he was irrelevant you know excuse me
right
or sorry i was thinking thomas massey
but uh louis gomer but again still the
same thing he was right you know
trending
when they had that j6
uh
press briefing
let's let's go to that here let me let
me uh let me see if i can pull
that up here
um let's see
there it is
here here here we go this is this is the
uh clip
here uh if i can find it this is the
clip of louie gohmert you're talking
this is the press conference you're
talking about right the insurrectionist
yeah this is the one where they're like
it's they're so patriotic prisoners and
all this [ __ ] whatever the hell they
were i don't know
what what do you make of this
uh them trying to protect
the insurrectionist i mean do you think
it's like they think it's politically
smart or is it like they really are in
cahoots with these people so they're
trying to make sure yeah so i don't know
if they're directly in cahoots but i
think at a certain point anyone's
willing to talk and if they're on the
receiving end of that because someone is
in jail and they're like listen i want a
plea deal or i want some sort of deal to
get out of this [ __ ] and i somehow have
information from either myself or a
third party about these people for
something that was done you know
it's like uh
but at the same time it's like you've
got these representatives who are like
oh we're fighting for these j6 people
which
it's like the people tried to overthrow
the government they went in and they you
know
they
people died
either directly or indirectly from it
uh they destroyed a bunch of property
causing millions of dollars in damages
and
there was theft and
vandalism and all sorts of things and
here they are going like these people
are so unfairly treated
if that person was of a different skin
color that was not white or they were
anywhere else you know especially
a group that might potentially put them
in legal trouble right they would be
harping on them until end of time
well i mean look at look at um for
instance you see
uh black lives matter protest and there
were a few
not just politicians but also famous
people who did like a gofundme type
thing
to get those people released and to pay
for some of the legal fees they talked
about that for months oh look they're
defending criminals and all this [ __ ]
now um the tweet here is louis gomer
suggests that federal agents should be
charged with insurrection for stirring
up things on january 6. i'm actually not
going to play this clip of louie gohmert
because i don't want to listen to him
and really honestly he got such a little
of the vote i don't know yet other than
him saying stirring up things i am going
to it's the same
it's the same [ __ ] that like tucker
carlson and other people are trying to
push which is this like conspiracy
theory that while there were informants
or other people associated with the fbi
they were the ones that instigated they
were the ones that did this whole thing
and then planted
this whole
uh insurrection on these people as fault
as like fall guys
and that's the narrative he's trying to
push here which is like dude
you're this is really the hill you want
to die on like this i actually think it
is the hill they're dying because here's
what i actually think is going on
they're sending messages to tv uh court
or excuse me jailhouse tvs because um
most inmates uh have access to
television right so i think what part of
the um the bet here is is that they'll
end up on tv talking about these january
6 insurrectionist and it'll start to go
around the jailhouse there that louis
gohmert is suggesting that the fbi
is is part of this scheme to keep these
people in prison and the reason why i
think that that is to their favor is
because you see a lot of these [ __ ]
these boneheads that are locked up from
january 6 defending themselves in front
of federal judges and they're just
making it worse on themselves not
necessarily making it worse on the
people who helped them planned ie louis
gomer marjorie taylor green matt gatz
goes-r biggs
all these people in congress that
possibly had a
hand in helping the plan it's putting
more pressure on them in the court which
is only driving their process faster in
the court which makes them to a
conviction which the faster these
january 6 insurrectionists are actually
to a conviction and sentenced to prison
or home confinement is better for these
people because that means they're not in
front of a federal prosecutor uh giving
information that's my opinion of it but
maybe i'm wrong yeah yeah i mean even
the people that you know there's a you
know the q anon shaman and the other one
that was sentenced the mma fighter i
think is the other one they got sensed
for 41 42 months or what have you and
then
now
you know repre there was that whole
thing of like who is the represented
like who is the lawyer is it john pierce
aka the
you know we've talked about him before
uh as like he's the one who previously
represented uh kyle ridden house and you
know
raise all that money and then right and
this is the one kyle rittenhouse has now
kind of turned on right
right
and so
uh yeah yeah and he's the one who's like
lynn wood is crazy and then obviously
you know that that whole basis
can't take it
but um
yeah it's uh those people have now after
admitting guilt and saying you know i i
was there or whatever and i've taken
this sentencing now they're trying to
come back and be like no i want to
appeal it
which is a whole another mess
so yeah
well and and i you know i think a lot of
this is going to continue to go on
as these people are terrified that if
they are in cahoots with them is to you
know
uh you know do we
you see the image here uh
paulie paulie teaks did this uh image i
can't find his original tweet but he's
got credit in this week so we'll this is
our next this is our next contestant
kind of a kind of a quick transition
there
yeah it really went you know yeah well
deep into that one right deep balls deep
into the massey uh
debacle here which is again a great a
great image because he really is a dick
right i don't know i would say he's a
small like he's a he's a big dick has a
small dick right you know and here he is
children are being big dicks too right
this is like this this screams uh
tiny dick energy like not even little
dick energy this is tiny
dick itty-bitty even they're holding
huge dicks it's right energy yeah so i'm
gonna give credit for this since we
showed it um i know that there were some
people on twitter who uh yuri who are
getting their accounts partially uh
in in twitter that's not what we want
because
they were sharing that image
right
oh oh because because it wasn't you know
it was like graphic or it wasn't real or
whatever the [ __ ] i don't know it was
some dumb excuse but
since then people have you know that
they've been fine
but i would say it actually uh made the
image much better because in the other
one they're all holding a bunch of
[ __ ] assault rifles and different
guns and telling us to have a safe
holiday
but the reason obviously that he made
this list is because just a few days
after
the shooting
in
michigan
he decides it's a smart idea to post
that [ __ ] so here's his his his this
is his tweet i'm not gonna give him
credit here but this is the original
picture right
which i'm like how many guns like
does each person in this family own one
of these guns and what do they use these
guns for
right move that banner no i i'm i'm
telling you this is
um this family here
uh and we talked about this where we
came on the air like no one knew who the
[ __ ] this guy was until this picture
like this is this is everyone's like
thomas massey who even even with the
horrible tornadoes that destroyed part
of kentucky
um and i believe part of his district no
one even would even you know people were
questioning you know this is the guy
that's trying to help you you know he's
worried about his guns and [ __ ] yeah um
and he's the guy you know he's paying
attention to christmas trees and guns
instead of like real policy that can
make sure that people in kentucky can
get fema money right and disaster relief
money this [ __ ] voted the same
way rand paul voted every single time
since he's been in congress every
[ __ ] time against disaster relief
other places than in kentucky it's been
really interesting to see
republican law and i mean i had a tweet
yesterday about this is like
this is another event in 2021
specifically where another
looking locker has in the past voted
against federal aid for other you know
right
uh hurricane sandy and
um well any of them houston yeah
remember when houston got hit ted cruz
was begging right right same time uh
kennedy was begging because there was
the you know the hurricane but
how quickly they flip because like
during like oh we're not going to give
any federal funding socialism why would
we help out these people when they need
help the most like oh like puerto rico
forget it you know whatever like natural
disaster happens and then it hits their
their you know their backyard and then
they go oh oh please please please
please please can we get assistance and
aid and it's like dude these these
lawmakers are failing their constituents
and making them ill-prepared
but
the the the karma that comes back
unfortunately for these people
who
did or did not vote them in whatever the
case may be are
unfortunately on the receiving end of
the poor decisions
uh in an ill-prepared
kind of state these uh republican
lawmakers have put them in and then of
course joe biden without sort of any
hesitation says yeah yeah eight is
coming yeah why would i mean honestly
the the disaster that happened in
kentucky this weekend is of no fault of
any kentuckians right no this this
[ __ ] bonehead here on the screen or
rand paul or anyone else
and america should put their
full-throated uh support socialist
support i'll say it we should put the
full-throated socialism behind this
country that we already have in this
country that
where we have fema uh where we have
federal help national guard those are
socialism folks right that's socialism
and we should put the full-throated
socialism in this country to rebuild
kentucky full stop without hesitation um
they are america they are part of they
are part of our country and we should
full throat it but what we also should
do in the meantime is call out dumb
bucks like this and rand paul to say
they didn't want anyone else to have it
and the only reason why they want you to
have socialism is because it's good for
them not for you not for people in
kentucky because honestly if they're
willing to look at houston or sandy uh
hurricane sandy or the gulf anywhere
else and go oh you don't deserve it they
don't believe kentuckians deserve it
either it's only for their own
self-interest just like this stupid
[ __ ] picture that this idiot has here
and that's the other thing too is like
you got rand paul libertarian and oh my
gosh how those values just fall apart as
soon as they need some sort of federal
aid like for a natural disaster you know
of course they're against the funding
and they want small government and they
don't want to do this and don't want to
do that but then what's the first thing
they ask for as soon as something
happens
help yeah and it's like oh doesn't that
tell you i mean if you really want to
play by that game then unfortunately you
wouldn't get anything you know right
on the other end but of course of course
of course here's the game we play back
and forth because here democrats are
saying yes we should give the full throw
to government help from the government
whether it be the federal government
state government whatever we can do to
make sure that kentucky gets the aid
they need to rebuild in this time of
need right as fast as they possibly can
especially during the time of christmas
and the other thing too especially you
know for
i you know i saw uh rex chapman post
about it and and several other people
which is like
we have failed
as a
a governmental body because of dumb
[ __ ] like these right where they say no
no
the reserves the aid they don't need
them so they aren't prepared and so it
becomes this like emergency situation
where they need you know big government
to come in
and also it's it directly relates to
things like health care where it's like
oh now i got to start a go [ __ ] a
[ __ ] gofundme to
fund my bills and then you've got you
know celebrities and personalities and
bigger people who are like let's come
together and raise money
for this
event that happened right i'm going to
go to rex because i want to i want a
good note uh while we're broadcasting
here right um actually i i don't know
but it's just one of those things where
it's like
you know these these lawmakers have
failed so now it comes down to the
citizen
to like reach out and be like dude we
need to [ __ ] do something right now
can we watch rex's video here real quick
okay let's let's watch this video
hi guys um my home state of kentucky is
devastated right now with the tornado
that hit western western kentucky last
night
i'm born and raised in western kentucky
lived the first 18 years of my life
there
people are hurting right now here before
the holidays death
destruction
i've partnered with bluegrass community
foundation again
it's going to take more a lot more than
money to help rebuild western kentucky
and mayfield but
i've partnered with bluegrass
community foundation again
and every dollar that's donated will go
to people
in need
around this time of the year
down in the western part of the state so
thank you donate if you can if you can't
no worries
merry christmas happy holidays everyone
much love team game donate
so there's good people out there right
right right and rex rex is one of them
good people who have to unfortunately
and and thankfully and gratefully have
to pick up the mess
of the representatives from those states
who have failed right like for for
instance right you've got texas they've
got uh
they within six months of each other
they had both a cold like a winter storm
and then they had a a
which took down the grid and then they
had a heat uh
that also
you know messed with their power
and you've got people like aoc who are
fundraising for behalf for texas on
behalf of texas and does more work and
raises more funds than any of the
governor senators representatives anyone
else who's uh who's who's supposed to be
working but at the same time has in the
past voted against any sort of aid to
any other state for any other crisis or
disaster and then again when it comes to
their you know it comes knocking on the
front door
they've either like jumped ship and gone
to cancun
or you've got someone else who has
uh just this even the slightest bit of
compassion and empathy towards people
and their suffering to say we need to do
something and so they do something on
their behalf when their representatives
have failed them right and this is
another example well speaking of failed
representatives look at our dishonorable
mention of the week here we are back to
uh
lauren bobo bobert of course she was
trending today and and bobo is still
trending uh let me let me bring that up
here let me bring that feed up here i'm
actually kind of a little
kind of a little uh
hey look look we're at the very top
um you're you're at the very top with
with our feet here um i i think this is
really [ __ ] dumb of why we have bobo
trending because let me go to the tweet
here here's a screenshot of it
she she says 365
3448 children were went missing in 2020.
now there's a lot wrong with this tweet
in one packet a little bit before we get
to the bone in the actual winner uh you
haven't heard a word from the media
about it there in line is the problem
now if you look down here at the bottom
and there in line she spelled it wrong
and and twitter went crazy about this
phrase which hey hey twitter hey
liberals on twitter i'm gonna [ __ ]
call you out that is the [ __ ] dumbest
reason why this why she's trending for
this tweet number one the first sentence
is a total [ __ ] lie number two the
first sentence if it is the truth 2020
donald trump was president why are we
taking this up with the media who said
nothing about it and honestly the media
is the only one that talks about missing
children anywhere so
um there's a lot more problems with this
[ __ ] tweet than her misspelling and
you know i'm i'm all for lauren bobert
being dumb and all this but we're really
we really need to focus on the issue
here that this [ __ ] idiot is
spreading propaganda to to
a lot of people in this country when she
says stupid [ __ ] like this because this
is
this is uh borderline inciting violence
because what she's telling mothers out
there is that no one wants to tell you
that children are missing which is
completely [ __ ] not the truth right
exactly truth not even close to the
truth that is all [ __ ] now i
understand that a lot of missing
children reports get um
get lost in the news but that is a bunch
of [ __ ] [ __ ] and for you people
you [ __ ] liberals you people who say
you're pro-democracy out there to harp
on her because she misspelled a word
you
are gonna end up on bonehead of the week
if you're not careful because there is
so much more wrong with this tweet than
her [ __ ] misspelling it and then
that's my soapbox um but no i i totally
agree that it's that it's harping not
like you know
lauren beauberg
not too smart we all agree on that and
right uh she has
done other grammatical errors before
which i would say are more newsworthy
right but for something like this was
like therein lies it's like ah it's
whatever but by harping and focusing on
those two words
you forget the action
which is the right yeah which again is
his first sentence which is claim this
number also in 2020 when trump is
president so now all of a sudden it's
like all these things that happen when
trump is president are biden's problems
right yes he did inherit problems that
he does have to fix but the tweet in and
of itself is pointing out an issue with
the trump administration and it's a
total [ __ ] lie right and so
you know it's that right there we're
like oh i'm going to focus on the last
thing that was said here as opposed to
you know this is the same thing this is
the same thing gabe you have this when
people come into your
into your videos right like your your
thread comments and they're like oh
you you're you're this or you're oh they
they say i'm fat a lot like oh chubby
like oh yeah okay good one
like going after lauren beaubert for
this tweet because she misspelled there
in lies
is really [ __ ] stupid it's really
there's plenty to tear apart about this
idiot's
cause she's saying [ __ ] [ __ ] that's
trying to
incite and cite people's uh
vitriol feelings about
child abductions she's lying she's she's
trying to exploit child abductions
to gain political points here and you
people are [ __ ] worried about how
she's spelling words i don't care if she
misspelled 100 words or she didn't
misspell anything about this tweet this
tweet has nothing to do with your
spelling okay
yeah the last thing i'll say is like you
know it again it's the whole thing of
it's there is projection in all the
things that are said right you're a
party
who
you got uh what's face uh duggar right
that just
oh yes yes uh yeah yeah and so again
example right uh none of the republicans
really want to talk about that despite
the fact that he had all these
connections with different people
and
you know it's like oh let's let's take
care of the children let's let's protect
the children and it's like
okay well then let's focus on the group
that's actually causing the problems but
they just want to project it as if it's
some sort of
issue not their problem democrats are
the problem it's biden's problem that
needs to be fixed right well i mean if
you're so worried about the exploitation
of children maybe you should speak out
against the republicans in arkansas uh
starting with josh duggar and possibly
looking at uh
uh
daddy pedo which
jim j
listen josh duggar uh was probably
taught how to be what he is
in my mind so um we have uh let's of
course our winner of the week is uh
marjorie hoof foot green i call her
marjory hill foot green marjorie taylor
green is our winner so let's let's let's
give her her a do and players
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so she's the bone end of the week um now
i'm gonna play a video here because gabe
brought it up and i think it's a kind of
a funny video and it just it just shows
how fake these [ __ ] people are right
um but uh and i've already given credit
for it but she's she's here on the house
floor speaking about uh something
specific and she speaks uh uh she thinks
she's not being miked right and she's
speaking she's even trying to cover it
um and she says something here so let's
it's not very long so let's play what
she says what purpose is it generally
from georgia rice i don't want any of
that
for what purpose is the gen lady from
georgia rice madam speaker is the member
so she's on the floor now this process
if people don't know
um
they were voting here
is what they were doing and she she is
rising to to proxy vote okay
that's what's good i don't even i don't
even have to watch the full clip um to
know that's what's going on here because
that's that's one thing that the other
pro democracy people out there need to
get get in line with they need to start
watching the boring ass c-span to figure
out uh how the floor process works and
how passing bills work we would be much
more in tune with each other
but this here she's proxy voting so
she's trying to take time on the floor
to proxy vote for someone else so she's
calling for time on the floor to speak
and that's when the president uh in the
chamber uh
says
gives her time officially and she the
mic is hot and she's what is she saying
something about wine right yeah she's
saying i don't want none of that screw
top stuff which is basically she wants
the she wants the good stuff she wants
the cork stuff right right screw top is
for is for sure white trash
yeah yeah and she's better than that you
know right which which basically she's
all all the people that probably give
her money drink screw top [ __ ] right
really well honestly they probably don't
even drink wine they probably drink like
mad dog 20 20 like like some kind of
malt we've all been there hey no
judgment i'm not you know boone's farm
i'm not i'm not knocking it you gotta
you know it's it's [ __ ] that you gotta
drink sometimes yeah you know sometimes
you're on a [ __ ] budget apparently
marjorie taylor green is not on a budget
which yeah i actually think that that
uh
yeah she we we shouldn't really be
pissed off about this her constitution
should be like what do you mean you
don't like screw top that's my favorite
kind you [ __ ] that's what i think they
would say i'm just saying i'm just
saying okay so she also and i
to to credit to andy duffer here she
also does sound like she had already
maybe tossed a couple back
she's our she's she's this loose gavin
you know and well if you think that
these [ __ ] politicians aren't going
to the floor and voting while they're
wasted come on the [ __ ] on jesus of
course they are they're probably
drinking on a regular basis like by noon
they're [ __ ] slammed
100 100 andy's right i gave him credit
here thank you andy for
bringing bringing the hypocrisy because
that's what this is when she's saying
the screw top stuff because it you
notice she was a little embarrassed
because if she was gonna do a commercial
she'd be like yeah i'd drink screw top
wine like like all the rest of the
regular folks out there that shoot guns
and love jesus that's what you would say
i'm just saying
it's true i'm just saying that's what
she would say if she would say it out in
the open not on the floor like this in
front of a hot mic and be embarrassed so
let's get to the reason why she was on
bonehead of the week because i think
that's important too
uh you know these that the
insurrectionist threw a
insurrection uh press conference here to
defend the what they call political
prisoners and and they're just prisoners
is what they are because they right
right
right they're accused of committing
crime they've been charged with the
crimes so some of them because the judge
doesn't think it's a good idea to have
them released because of some of those
crimes or their past history they're
being held in jail some of them are not
some of them don't even have like ankle
bracelets on some of these people are
just out running around that showed up
on the capital lawn and you know that
broke windows and [ __ ] they're nice it's
nice to be white you know well you know
it is uh sometimes it can be that way
apparently probably
more than likely hundred percent that's
where i'm going um aaron actually posted
a couple three uh two videos on the
thread here i think we should watch both
of them
um this is where
um he says marjorie taylor green claims
that the january 6 defendants are told
quote they have to denounce president
trump and they are told that their views
are views of cult members now what she's
talking about here i think is she's
speaking about the
the lawyers that they've been given for
public defendants
is that what you're getting or do you
think in the press conference because
it's kind of like word salad right but
yeah they i mean they don't really say
there isn't like
anything of substance that they say here
they're just like just moving mouths
whether to send a message or not but
yeah it's one of those things where
they're just like
i also
i don't know i mean part of me thinks
it's just a safe face
in a way on their end to be like we're
fighting for you you know but really
they're not doing [ __ ] right well right
again i think that this is the same
press conference that we played earlier
with louie gohmert right uh and i think
he spoke before uh marjorie taylor yeah
he had an old display ready to go like
yeah spent resources and money right
right pushing the big lie right and to
push this idea that hey hang in there
you prisoners don't tell on us right so
let's let's listen to the [ __ ] bone
in here
and the treatment is unbelievable they
are told they have to denounce president
trump
they are told that their views are the
views of cult members even though these
are men that every single night at nine
o'clock at night they put their hand
over their heart and sing the national
anthem voluntarily
doesn't that like they all do it
voluntarily in prison you're going to
tell me that every single one of them
felt like like like in in sync at 9pm
puts their hand over their heart right
praise to god sounds a little culty
right yeah it sounds culty
you know i'm sure this is one person in
there that was like someone's like hey
you probably should shut the [ __ ] up
about trump because he's not president
and then they took that game of
telephone or interpret it however they
want right and they're like you got to
denounce trump you know or someone was
like how about you
you know wake up and get out of the cult
and then from there
i mean
here's the story if i'm if i'm a defense
attorney right and i'm and and i'm uh
poised to defend these people like i'm
like hey your best chance in front of a
judge
is to tell the judge you were duped by
donald trump because the judge is going
to know that you would do by donald
trump you're a dummy and you had no clue
that this was a cult and and it is a
cult and you know that type of language
to get leniency
like that's what i would like that's
your best chance here yeah that's right
it's at that point where it's like you
committed a crime you now have to pay
the consequences and to get a reduced
sentence or you know uh
consequence for what you did
you have to go to the judge and say like
listen i realize what i did was
misguided and i was i was sent right
along a a a
misguided path by a man who had duped us
all right as opposed to
i believe in what i did and the things
that i did i still believe in and i have
not i have not grown in the months that
i've been in prison i have not changed
my viewpoint i would do it again
in a heartbeat right and
it's like dude listen whether you meet
her or not just shut the [ __ ] up and say
that
you don't you don't feel this way
anymore right but now it's like marjorie
janet the green and the rest of these
[ __ ]
conservatives
you know uh come in there and say oh no
they're being indoctrinated and told
that they need to
remove themselves and denounce trump and
all this [ __ ] and it's like well
here's here's the next clip because
you're getting right to the heart of it
here now what's funny is we did a video
several weeks ago or we showed a video
on the podcast um during thanksgiving it
was called booksgiving it had uh jo jojo
from jurors she did her satirical
character becky sue
and we actually on the clip it's it's
real news really news now it's the
satirical news network that we have and
you played carl tuckerson in the clip
and in the clip becky sue calls crt
critical race training now we that was
totally [ __ ] made up yeah that was
that was the wednesday before
thanksgiving right
right and it wasn't actual parody it was
an actual satire now we didn't know this
at the time we thought it was but it was
a prediction that's what joey said i
think yeah
but marjorie taylor green says here the
defendants are getting pumped full of
critical race theory training in jail
let's listen to this [ __ ] bone-it
represented by afford to pay a lawyer
and they're being represented by public
defenders that call them white
supremacists tell them they have to
denounce president trump tell them they
have to denounce their political views
want them to watch videos and read books
that i mean basically is critical race
theory training in order for them to
have this public defender represent them
you see that's the political bias in the
court let me excuse me let me go oh my
god i don't know what videos but i would
say just like i said a moment ago
reading is good right right reading
regardless oh well i would say like mine
comp maybe stay away from that one right
you know like madison cawthorne probably
has it by his bedside table right right
uh i would i would probably say like hey
reading is good because you know it
helps you
uh in terms of like uh
right learning you know and like
thinking yeah you know knowing truth
being cognitive of you know like things
around you giving you hopefully some
like
valuable knowledge
uh but unfortunately they're according
to marcher taylor green they are
having to watch videos and read books
that are pumping them with critical race
training
and it's just critical race training
here's jo jojo's tweet i want to include
it because uh she re she reposted our
clip here but she says marjorie's three
names is
walking talking parody critical race
theory training quotes we made a
satirical video about crt it was meant
to be fictional it turned out to be a
prediction and joe is completely right
it it it really you can't make this [ __ ]
up man yeah it's it's actually kind of
sad that what made
two weeks later and we're like
nostradamus up in this [ __ ] it's
[ __ ] insanity that our stupid joke
gets it our joke made it into a
microphone into a real [ __ ] press
conference
with four sitting congress people who
are talking about the [ __ ] deadly
insurrection who also later go on to
talk about how they are going to be the
future of the gop yeah matt gets he says
the words when we take power he says the
words
when we
take
there's nothing more [ __ ] fascist
than the way like most politicians would
be like
when we win the election right when the
mid terms swing our way when we take the
majority of the house of representatives
he says
when we take power holy actual [ __ ]
these people are not trying to hide it
anymore they are [ __ ] boneheads let
me play one more time to congratulate uh
marjorie taylor greenier on her win
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so congratulations to marjorie hoof foot
green
for winning the bonehead of the week
congratulations you [ __ ] idiot um
again if you want to vote for next
week's i don't know exactly who's going
to make it on there uh the list is
accumulating as we speak but just follow
us on twitter at tony michael's pod also
follow me and gabe and you can go to the
tony michael's pod and our handles are
there as well it's at the tony michaels
and i am gabe sanchez follow us there
also subscribe to the youtube channel
because you can come re-watch the
bonehead of the week if you need to
if you don't catch it on twitch or if
you catch it if you don't catch it on
twitter on our accounts you can
subscribe to the youtube channel so go
there and subscribe just uh searching
tony michael's pod or tony michael's
podcast you'll find it there you can
find all the leaks on the
tonymichaels.com
also if you want to get your favorite
idiot on the list
to possibly be a candidate for bonehead
of the week go to
boneheadoftheweek.com you can make your
recommendation there
and you go to the tonymichaels.com that
link is also uh there
uh boneheadoftheweek.com to give us your
suggestions i think we have a lot of uh
people to work with next week um even
maybe some of these boneheads still
standing in this press conference
possibly uh lauren bobert really looks
like she's gonna make her way under the
list possibly she's always trying she's
i think it's anyone's game every week
it's anyone's game right you know right
this is it you know at uh we started
this show to try to highlight uh some of
the stupidity and give give
yeah
um
let people know that hey this stuff is
[ __ ] you need to know about these people
and we're hoping that it kind of breaks
through to uh other boneheads that vote
for these boneheads but you know that's
maybe a wishful thinking but we should
at least know and try to spread around
because everyone gives me [ __ ] about
that why are you pointing this out why
are you talking about these people stop
talking about them we need to know what
they're doing like how are you gonna
know that these people these people have
power it's not like marjorie taylor
green
controls the cash register at the
quickie stop down the road she is a
member of congress like she is she is
poised to set policy now
luckily she doesn't have any committee
uh assignments which hopefully we can
get to the point where none of these
seditious [ __ ] have committee
assignments and maybe they're expelled
what do you think
uh that would be a dream come true if i
could have any sort if like if there was
any sort of god out there or if i wanted
to make a one new year's resolution or
like you know prayer or whatever it
would be
that every one of these uh
sedition
uh sedition sisters yeah
sedition sisters that's like that's a
good that could be a good sitcom
um
but any of these seditionists
i hope to be either expelled from
congress or uh you know if
which i hope these the january 6
committee is beginning to reveal that
there's a lot more that was happening
behind the scenes despite the fact that
they were like oh nothing's happening
nothing's happening everyone's like oh
nothing's gonna happen or they they
weren't involved only to find out
powerpoints phone records communications
this and that i'm hoping that 2022
brings about the type of punishment or
at least uh uh accountability yeah yeah
i i i think there's accountability
coming i think there's accountability
coming because a lot of people have been
talking about how members of congress
haven't been subpoenaed by january 6th
select committee yet i think there's a
lot of reasons for that and the one
reason for that is um that there is
going to i i believe that at some point
there is going to be a list of members
who are going to go to the floor and
going to be expelled with a vote um it's
happened before in our country i think
it's going to happen again i think the
evidence points towards that i think the
reason why the january 6 select
committee hasn't subpoenaed some of
these people is because some of these
people are poised to
be in criminal trouble and they don't
want to affect a criminal trial so hang
on to your hats kids be positive be
positive and stay with us at bone of the
week come come you know come listen next
week go vote when we get that vote out
there uh be watching for it we'll
retweet it we'll try to spread it around
like herpes on twitter so that you can
see it you can vote i'm just saying i'm
just saying
what what
sometimes spreading herpes is bad
sometimes spreading herpes is like
spreading the bone end of the week so
yeah so our viewers get to vote so at
least the viewers don't have it and
those boneheads do that's right that's
right thanks thanks for staying with us
and thanks for coming and watching us
again follow us on twitter on on youtube
and stay with us and before we go [ __ ]
em [ __ ] em
[Music]
[Applause]